Notre Europe aujourd'hui est mortelle,
elle peut mourir.
La bataille n'est pas encore gagnée,
loin de là,
et qu'à l'horizon de la prochaine décennie,
le risque est immense
d'être fragilisé,
voire relégué.
Nous devons
être lucides sur le fait que notre Europe aujourd'hui
est mortelle, elle peut mourir.
Nous ne sommes pas armés face
au risque qui est le nôtre et l'Europe est dans 1
situation d'encerclement
poussé
par nombre de ses puissances à ses frontières et
parfois en son sein.
Et donc oui, nous sommes aujourd'hui encore trop lent.
L'Europe doit savoir défendre ce qui lui est cher
avec ses alliés,
à chaque fois qu'ils sont prêts à le faire à nos côtés
et seuls si c'est nécessaire.
Est-ce que pour ça il nous faut 1 bouclier anti missile ?
Peut-être.